to the girls who stay smart
he was a titan in the world of musical
theater
[Music]
everybody revered for the sharp witty
lyrics he composed to some of our best
loved musicals from company to sweeney
todd stephen sondheim who has died at
the age of 91 spent a six decade long
career pioneering musical comedy earning
nine tony awards an oscar for dick tracy
and even a pulitzer
has to shield you
his work transcended broadway with shows
such as into the woods adapted for the
silver screen along with two film
adaptations of west side story the
latest by steven spielberg about to come
out in cinemas now and reaching a new
generation of musical lovers
[Music]
[Applause]
when sondheim won a presidential medal
of freedom in 2015 barack obama said he
reinvented the american musical and in
the lowest moments of lockdown his music
and lyrics served as a tonic his 90th
birthday tribute doubling as an event
for artists against poverty
[Music]
tributes have poured in with barbra
streisand writing thank the lord that
sondheim lived to be 91 years old so he
had the time to write such wonderful
music and great lyrics composer andrew
lloyd webber wrote farewell steve the
musical giant of our times an
inspiration not just to two but to three
generations your contribution to theater
will never be equaled
stephen
the cast of company
dedicate this performance to you
stephen sondheim was universally admired
for his perfectionism and originality
i've done it three or four times
his death casting a long shadow over the
bright lights of broadway
katie spencer sky news